Speaker 1: Let's go next to Charlie from Toledo.
You're on the Air Charlie.
Speaker 2: Hi, sir, how are you doing?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well, sir, thank you.
Speaker 2: Good, I'm at work, so it's pretty loud,
so I'll get off pretty soon.
Speaker 1: Is there a lave
you could maybe run to make it even louder?
Speaker 2: Yes, sir, I'm at a lead right now.
Speaker 1: OK, good. All right. Well, let's go.
Speaker 2: I guess the the question I have is
it's really an observation, which is I hear
this talking point a lot about school lunch.
You know, it shouldn't be free because
kids are going to become socialists, right?
But that's what school from the students
perspective, all of school is free.
So why don't we make them pay tuition for public
school? That's basically your observation.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And I mean, it's it's it's
absurd on a number of levels, which is also like.
It's always kind of free to the students because
most of them are just getting money from their
parents anyway. And also, it's all sort of not
free because it's all being paid for by their
parents property taxes or if their parents rent
by the property taxes that their parents rent is
paying for for whoever is the landlord. I mean,
it's all kind of absurd. Even the use of the word
free is kind of silly because most people, once
you get past third grade, you kind of understand
nothing's really free. It's just who's paying for
it. And you're right. Like, there's no big tragedy
in kids not having to bring cash for school
lunch. We're going to be OK as a society, even
with free at the point of sale school lunches.
Speaker 2: Yes, sir, I agree. Thank you for
taking my call. All right, thank you.
Speaker 1: Very, very pithy and concise.
OK, we're going to take a very quick break.
We'll keep taking calls, so don't hang up
if you're holding on to talk
to me. We'll be right back.